the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode hey
good morning everybody it's uh Thursday
morning July 21st uh thanks for taking
the time out of your schedule to join us
today on this special presentation uh my
name is Michael baltos and today I'll be
talking about trading the order flow you
know professional trading strategies
strategies that uh you know professional
Traders use every day in the markets
so
I'll just let the I just turned 10
o'clock there's still people coming into
the room you know I'll just give them a
chance to come in but um you know really
what I just want to stress is there's so
many different ways to approach the
market and trading order flow is the way
that I approach the market and it's the
way that I was taught since you know I
started my training career on the
trading floor at the CME uh in the early
1990s and you know it served me well
through the years and you know I've I've
been able to make a nice comfortable
living through trading and you know my
goal for you today is you know for you
also to understand the order flow so
if you've been trading for any length of
time you know that there's a vast amount
of information out there right it can be
overwhelming trying to sift through it
all and figure out what is relevant to
you and your trading style like I said
you know everybody has their own trading
Style no two people trade exactly alike
and that's why I'm glad you took the
time to join me on this quick training
session and today what you're going to
learn is you're going to discover how
professional Traders use the order flow
to their advantage I'm going to teach
you how to identify when there's a
change in the order flow and how to use
order flow to spot opportunities in the
market right that's really the whole
point of using order flow is to spot
those opportunities especially the
opportunities that people who aren't
using order flow just don't see in the
market so if you're new to one of my
presentations
you know I've been partnering with
investors Expo for a while but if you're
new here uh just a brief background on
on who I am like I said I started my
trading career on the CME floor
in the 1990s with Deanwood Reynolds when
electronic trading started taking off I
left the trading floor to go work on
their off the floor trading desk uh
trading you know Globex which was the
CME project day which was uh the Board
of Trade
nymex calmex system which was called
access as well as all the international
exchanges you know exchanges in Asia
Singapore Japan
um Europe you know the life
dtp or urex has you know it used to be
called dtb but you know the RX exchange
is as well as all the exchanges around
the world and it really opened my eyes
up into you know how the markets really
move as opposed to you know being on a
trading floor you're just focused on one
and maybe two markets after Dean winner
I joined the trading desk at EDF man in
Chicago the macro Futures Trading desk
and after a couple years I joined
Commerce Bank I was a licensed your ex
Trader there I was trading I was one of
the only a handful of people that were
legally allowed to trade buns Bobble
shats Stacks Euro stocks
in the U.S on the actual exchange
terminal
after a Commerce Bank you know I took
some time off I traveled the world for
about six months and I joined the the
trading desk at Cargill in Chicago
This was um
you know a big if you're not familiar
with cargo it's a big commodity trading
firm it's a privately held firm but if
it was a publicly held firm it would be
you know it varies from the the first or
second largest firm in the United States
uh privately held if it was publicly
held it would probably rank about eighth
or ninth and you know they account for
about 30 percent of U.S grain exports
about 25 percent of meat exports but
they trade everything there as well
after Cargill they actually cargo sent
me out to Singapore to set up a trading
desk when the exchange was closing down
and that's how I ended up working for JP
Morgan in Singapore I spent eight years
there as vice president of Futures
Trading
and after you know my daughter was born
I left JP Morgan to basically trade for
myself right because I realized you know
I know how to trade I know what matters
in the market I don't need to spend 12
hours a day in the office right I could
do this for myself and
I started writing a book on trading um
it was called uh trading the order flow
and
eventually the software that I was using
you know really wasn't that
robust it was just a basic charting
software of plotting the order flow and
so I started my own company the
orderflows.com which
I incorporate my forms of analysis into
the order flow so that was you know 2015
that that happened so we've been going
on on eight years already and again you
know I created my own software because
the software that was out there just
wasn't good enough right it was just
basic right but software you know
computer programs exist to help you
become a better Trader
now the reason I talk about that is
because you know the charts that I'm
using in this presentation are generated
from my order flow software okay but
what I'm teaching you can be used with
any software out there okay so hopefully
you can come away if you're not using
you know my software if you're using
um you know the systems there's trading
systems native order flow footprint
software you can apply what you're using
today
and again you know creating the software
it's been a big help for a lot of
Traders right Traders are you know
writing to me posting on social saying
you know your software allows me to see
who's in control of the market clearly
right and that's the whole point right
you want to be able to see clearly
what's happening in the market but more
importantly understand it and that's
where order flow comes in now brief
disclaimer you know trading does involve
risk
only risk Capital should be used for
trading
um and just bear that in mind right when
we're all adults here we do understand
the risks involved so how professional
Traders use the order flow to their
advantage now as a Trader I'm always
looking for ways to get an edge on the
competition right and the one tool that
I've found to be very useful is order
flow right so by understanding the order
flow I'm able to make better informed
trading decisions and you know this goes
all the way back 20 close to 30 years of
market knowledge right when I was on the
trading floor on the on the exchange
floor
you would have access to that order flow
information right that's why people paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
exchange memberships right so they can
see the flow of orders coming into the
market and trade with it trade against
it right that was the information
that was available if you're on the
trading floor if you're off the trading
floor watching ticks on the screen you
wouldn't be privy to who's buying and
who's selling and how strong that buy-in
selling was so order flow is simply a
way to organize the trades that happen
in the market and by tracking the order
flow Traders able to see which way the
market is moving but what you want to
look for is what the aggressive Traders
are doing in the market
because after all that's what causes the
markets to move is the aggressive
trading that's taking place
now remember
Market trade in a two-way auction okay
there are Traders bidding there are
Traders offering you know Market is five
bit at six right the emitters and you
have the sellers I mean people offering
it out so
when
you have people offering
and bidding these are passive Traders
but if you just have bids and offers the
Market's not going to move right I mean
the market could be five bit at six but
unless someone buys it at six the
Market's not going to start to move
higher or it's not going to move lower
if someone doesn't sell fives
you need aggressive Traders
right the ones that cross the bid offer
to get the trade done are the aggressive
Traders you know the traders who buy the
offer or the traders who sell the bid
are the aggressive Traders and if you
look at a dome right you mean you see
prices on the offer and above see bids
on the current bid level and Below these
are the passive buyers people working a
bid and below are Paths of buyers people
working the offer and above our passive
sellers the trader that crosses
you know currently this Market's uh
39.53 and a quarter offered at 53.75 for
a trade to happen someone has to go up
and pay
53.75 right that is being an aggressive
buyer or an aggressive seller is someone
that would sell it at
53 and a quarter
that is being aggressive right because
if you're just bidding and offering the
Market's not going to move right it'll
just stay stagnant there right until
someone goes in and buys the offer
um you know and that's an important
concept people don't realize they don't
realize the distinction between
aggressive trading and passive trading
now when a trade takes place where does
it show up it shows up on the time and
sales right and
it's from the time in sales that you're
able to get more information
I mean you'll see why that you'll see
different colors on the time and sales
right you'll see green numbers you'll
see these orange or red numbers and
that's telling you how it traded you
know is someone aggressively sold the
bid or aggressively bought the offer now
all that information
can be formatted into an order flow
chart right and that's going to start
giving you more information it's going
to tell you how much volume traded on
the bid how much volume traded on the
offer and once you start looking at that
then you could
get further right in your analysis right
you could see well okay in this bar
there was net aggressive selling or in
this bar there was net aggressive buying
or even things like where the volume is
sort of building up in a bar right is it
appearing sort of in the middle as as
you know normal distribution or is it
appearing on the edge you know at the
high or the low you know which could
indicate price
um defense or you know when you hit a
high
is there very little volume right I mean
like minimum volume like one contract
you know information like that there's
just so much little bits of information
that you as a Trader can take away and
use in your analysis
because
when you format the data into an order
flow footprint chart you can see not
only the volume traded in the auction
but you could determine the aggression
that's taking place or not taking place
all right imagine you know if it's like
trying to cook without a thermometer
right you don't know how hot the water
is right you don't I mean you can see if
it's boiling but you know turn on your
oven you think my oven is on but if you
don't know the temperature inside if
it's not hot enough your meat's going to
take a lot longer to cook
right you know if if you need to you
know bake the chicken at 400 or 350 but
you're don't know that the temperature
in your oven is only 250.
it's going to take a heck of a lot
longer to cook or again if you don't
know it and you take out your chicken
thinking it's cooked you bite into it
it's still frozen inside so you know
that's you know understanding the
aggression what's happening inside the
candle so to speak is going to give you
an edge over other Traders and a normal
Candlestick it just leaves out that
information it's just not there right
you see
um
you gotta open the high the low the
close it's very two-dimensional well I
wouldn't say two-dimensional it's more
of one-dimensional
okay I mean people like to say well
there was price rejection here because
they see price traded down and came back
up okay well is it really I'm going to
show you some examples where you know
these bars like this people say well
there's price rejection and you know the
market went up it's not right sometimes
there's heavy volume that's being traded
down here and if you can see that there
was you know heavy volume you know
there's price support there right
someone is defending that level and you
could expect the market to put in a
stronger move
so what's the information that you get
in the order flow that you can see on a
footprint chart is
it's it's a lot right you're getting
Delta Now Delta is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers
in the bar Max Delta again on a bar by
bar basis Max Delta is the strongest
reading of delta in the bar meaning you
know the highest
reading of aggressive buyers in the bar
Min Delta is the opposite it tells you
the strongest weak you know I don't want
to say the strongest weakest it's going
to tell you how weak the
the I said even how weak the bar was
it's going to tell you how strong the
aggressive sellers were in the bar it's
going to be a negative number right so
it's going to tell you how strong the
aggressive sellers were in that bar now
cumulative Delta
is
yeah you know every bar has a Delta
cumulative Delta is sort of the running
total of Delta for the trading session
up to that point so it could be you know
minus ten thousand meaning you know
usually if a market is is been selling
off all day you know you're going to
have negative Delta if a Mark has been
rallying all day you're gonna have
positive Delta but even within that you
know you can start drawing you can start
getting inferences in the market like is
um you know even though we're making a
new high you know is uh cumulative Delta
still rising or is it decreasing right
you have a Divergence in cumulative
Delta versus price you know that's a
nice opportunity to potentially get
short
now point of control
is the price level in the bar with the
most volume now some people refer to it
as commitment to Traders
um you know some of the earlier works on
on order flow you do see some people
talk about cot but point of control is
the price level in the bar with the most
volume
and you know that that's the term that's
used
um more often
now imbalance is also important right
imbalances you can see in the order flow
in a bar
you know in the two-way auction right
and that's very valuable information
seeing when a market is out of balance
right if you know that
the market is you know it's five bit at
six but you have
an imbalanced trading at six then
chances are it's going to quickly go to
seven right and if it's still in balance
between six bit at seven meaning more
aggressive buyers at seven you know
chances are we're going to go to eight
right so it's important to know where
these imbalances are coming in and think
of it like this think of imbalances like
this you know you
if you got kids I mean nowadays you know
you could shop on Amazon but um you know
in the old days right you go to you know
Christmas time there's always the hot
toys
and there's always big demand for these
and you you find yourself going around
to different toy stores finding it but a
lot of places are sold out you know
that's a sign of imbalances in the
market right because you have very
aggressive buying going into the holiday
season for a certain toy right but
everywhere sold out right and you do
find it at a place and it's like 50 more
like you know why you why is you know
the list prices is 29.95 you're selling
it at you know 39.95 well yeah it's
because you know the demand is greater
right when you see big demand you tend
to see imbalances
and this is all information that is
coming out of the marketplace right that
you're seeing
in the time and sales but I said you
know unless you have a way to format it
you're not going to understand it so
what do you think is more useful knowing
when and where aggressive trading is
taking place or only knowing the last
traded price you know the open the high
the low and the close as you would see
on a normal Candlestick chart so for
example right this is
e-mini s PS right mes now you know
people ask me all the time you know Mike
can I what is better to trade uh mes by
itself or trade mes off of the big
contracts you know use the big contracts
oh you could do both personally I think
um mes has got enough volume you can
trade it by itself granted it will move
in conjunction with the the big S PS but
if just getting back to imbalances right
imbalances are a sign of aggressive
Trading
so if you have buying imbalances
okay in a footprint it's going to be red
numbers in the footprint remember the
footprint tells you the volume that's
traded on the bid versus the volume
that's traded on the offer in the 2A
auction so if you see red numbers
in the footprint you know you have
aggressive selling if you see blue
numbers that's telling you you have
aggressive buying
so as this Market is just sort of going
sideways it makes this little push lower
you're seeing some aggressive selling
okay then the market sort of bottoms out
here and starts rallying and you're
seeing aggressive buying you're seeing
the blue numbers in the bar
you could even take it a little step
further you could be watching the Delta
right because Delta is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar and as the market
starts rallying right you're going to be
looking
for positive Deltas right and preferably
getting stronger
just as this Market that was going down
you're seeing negative Deltas but what
is interesting right as this Market is
sort of coming off here you got negative
Delta strong one minus 700 negative
Delta minus 400 negative Delta
minus 91 okay but then the aggressive
buying starts showing up now you've seen
positive Delta So Not only was the
aggressive selling getting weaker but as
it's turned you're seeing the aggressive
buying picking up right and this is
information again it's available to you
as a Trader it's whether or not you want
to use it right I don't understand why
Traders don't want to use it I mean it's
there
okay there's yes again right Market this
is just this morning right Market sold
off bounced up a little bit sold off
again right and if you can see just
which way are the aggressive Traders
going okay you got aggressive selling
one two three here there's one green bar
with some aggressive buying coming in
and then aggressive selling
this bar this bar this bar this bar this
bar this bar
right you can see the negative Delta
getting stronger it went from 18 to 94
to 415 right even here right markets
sold off bounced a little bit you got
one some positive this little pocket of
positive Delta as the market bounce then
it corrected itself and it came down
now where it gets interesting is you
know when you start looking at bars of
order flow right and you start looking
at
imbalances
you can start to group you know the
imbalances together right when you're
seeing bars that have multiple
imbalances that's a sign of you know
aggressive buyers coming out right now
Okay so
this bar here has got one two three four
bind imbalances this bar has got also
four this Bar's got three this Bar's got
five this Bar's got
five
but at the same time you know when
you're watching order flow sometimes it
gets a little tricky to recognize this
stuff because if the Market's trading
it's happening so fast
and there are easier ways to use it
right trading should be very visual I
mean we're very visual people nowadays
because of social media you know we're
scrolling through Instagram Facebook
watching you know YouTube shorts tick
tocks even
um
you know we want to be able to recognize
something that we will want to pay more
attention to very quickly right when
you're watching you know these these
little short tick tocks or whatever you
know after the first couple seconds
whether you want to watch it or not or
you just uh scroll
and
if you had a way on your chart to
quickly recognize where
multiple imbalances are coming in a bar
you know that's going to be useful to
you so you see this Market sort of
coming off here okay then you got a bar
here right you can with those multiple
imbalances this is the same chart as
this one right but what
my software does is it puts a box around
it just to highlight it to you to pay
attention right it's not a trade signal
oh you got multiple imbalances you got
to get long
or you got multiple selling imbalances
gotta get short no it's something to
draw your attention pay better attention
to the market the market was selling off
then I see quickly I got a borrow with
multiple buying imbalances okay you know
now I'm going to take it a little step
further and analyze this Market
right okay didn't go anywhere fine
Market starts selling off again I got
another bar this time it's multiple
selling imbalances
and another bar multiple cellular
balances okay I know now aggressive
selling is obviously in control I can
see the imbalances taking over this
Market I could see the negative deltas
yeah I could be short okay
now work it's interesting is when
markets make highs or lows or swing
highs or swing lows right this is mes
yesterday right we come down coming down
hot into this low
then you hit that low you bounce right
you turn you got that big bar up but
more importantly you got one two three
four five six seven buying imbalances in
this bar
off the low
what do you think the Market's doing
right you know there's aggressive buyers
you know aggressive buyers are the ones
that move the market well you want to
trade in that direction right you're not
looking to get short here thinking it's
going to come back down why why not is
because you know the aggressive buyers
are there
okay so that that's an edge that you're
going to have in the market over other
traders who don't know that there's
aggressive buying they're just guessing
that there's aggressive buying oh I got
a big green up bar it must be aggressive
traders in there
okay how many times have you seen a big
green up bar off a low then the next bar
big red down bar down into new lows
right you need that information to help
solidify
your trade idea
this is corn okay again whether you're
trading smps crude oil
currencies bonds even corn right a very
stale market for a lot of people that
aren't interested I'm just showing you
how the same things apply into other
markets this Market's just going
sideways here right it's going nowhere
it's going nowhere fast
then what happens you get the bar with
the bind imbalances in there one two
three minor balances
and it takes off
right people say well it didn't really
take off well in corn
you know this is what it's a 150 move
that happened in about
10 minutes 15 minutes
okay so you know the same things that
you would use on any Market can be
order flow the nice thing about order
flow is it transfers from one market to
the other right
forms of analysis whether you're trading
corn or Apple stock or you know Tesla or
s PS or you know wheat or anything buns
all right you'll be looking at this
looking for the same type of things
happening in every Market because you
know auctions trade the same whether
it's doesn't matter what Market it is
now the next part I want to talk about
is how to identify where there's a
change in order flow all right
you know Traders are always looking for
an edge to give them advantages of the
market
and one of the best ways to get that
edge is by recognizing for changes in
the order flow right I just showed you
the imbalances right that is one way
you're going to see changes in the order
flow
now when there's a shift in the order
flow it's going to Signal a change in
market conditions that can be exploited
for profit now there are a few ways to
do this one is to look at Price action
okay price action has got nothing to do
with order flow but when you start
combining price action with order flow
it's going to give you an extra Edge
over everybody else so if prices are
moving higher on increasing volume right
we know this this is uh Granville 101
there's a good sign that strong buying
pressure in the market conversely if
prices are falling on increasing volume
that indicates a strong selling pressure
yeah of course we know that
but there's other ways to gauge
order flow
and it's through the use of traded data
it's going to give you a direct look at
the buyers and sellers in the market so
again what are these areas of Market
generated information
well there's Delta there's Max Delta
there's Min Delta
point of control imbalances value areas
I didn't talk about value areas yet I
only get that a little bit later
but this is information
based on what is trading right now
another reason I got Max and Min Delta
highlighted there is because
I'm going to show you how to use that
internal data so just to reiterate Max
Delta is the strongest positive Delta
reading in a bar
Min Delta is the strongest negative
reading of delta in a bar
and think of it like this right think of
it like getting on a scale right and
seeing how much you weigh
excuse me we know that
you know if we hit a certain level on
our weight it's very high right we want
to ideally keep below that and that's
what Max and Min Deltas are they're
basically you know measurements of
strength
of aggressive buying or strength of
aggressive selling in a bar
all right so max Delta Min Delta how to
use it well when you're at a
swing high or swing low a potential
turning point in the market watch what's
happening internally in the bar
right because it's going to give you
insights that you know people just don't
see so the first one right we got the
swing High here
the Delta was minus 300 okay it's a nice
big negative number
fine sellers in there but what other
Traders sort of dismissed or don't
notice is that at one point this bar was
very
strong aggressive buying
it had 183 Max Delta so that's telling
you there was strong aggressive buying
but aggressive selling took over
quite strongly went from plus 183 to
minus 318 that's the Min Deltas minus
318. so that's a swing of almost 500
contracts
from aggressive you know from the max
Delta to the Min Delta and it closed
obviously at minus 300 so it closed at
quite a strong negative reading so you
know aggressive sellers are in control
right and the market sold off as
expected now where it gets interesting
is bars like this green bar here
early in this bar
you had
A Min Delta of minus three one nine
okay is that strong it's a strong
negative number
but it close to only minus five now the
max Delta was just 10.
so imagine right you had very strong
negative selling in this bar minus 300
and went from minus 300 just to minus
five
so the aggressive sellers were the
aggressive buyers rather excuse me the
aggressive buyers came in late in this
bar
to turn it just to minus five because
people say well you got negative Delta
the market should keep selling off well
no
if you can see that relationship of
the Min Delta to the final Delta
then you know that there was strong
aggressive buying coming into the market
to turn it around
and you see the market rallied a bit and
it rallied back up to you know the area
where you had that aggressive selling
um earlier
it's another example right this is gold
this bar right here minus 46 Min Delta
right minus 46 on the Delta is it's
quite a strong number in gold right this
is a 730
um yesterday morning all right it closed
at plus 33. so if you see this take this
minus 46 and if you had minus 46 in any
of these bars here even you know think
of it absolute terms it's a pretty
strong number
but it went from -46
and it
to plus 37 which is the max Delta
so that's a swing of you know close to
80 contracts and it closed up near its
Max Delta number plus 33. so you know
you had aggressive selling early in the
bar strong aggressive selling minus 46.
aggressive buying came in went from
minus 46 back to even went back to zero
then it continued
with the aggressive mind that
Progressive buying didn't just stop it
just it continued and it went from -46
to plus 37 before finally closing at 33.
what do you expect to happen well you
expect this Market to rally and it did
it got a nice quick rally over the next
seven or eight bars
okay
yes again okay so a few things this
first bar here right this first bar that
I got in this box
markets railing is making these highs
this is yesterday or we're making highs
and you get your first red candle here
it looked like okay maybe it's going to
stop and sell off
right you got the negative Delta the
next bar this bar here opens up you got
negative Delta it's at minus 247 in the
Delta okay yeah maybe we're gonna start
to sell off
but it doesn't Mark keeps rallying if
you're watching what's happening in the
Delta you can easily see that you know
there's still upside potential here
it went from -247 to plus 538 that's a
swing of you know seven close to 800
contracts from the aggressive selling to
aggressive buying it closed at plus 449
so you know there's still more to this
move
right so if you know if you were long
from earlier thinking oh should I take
profits
well after seeing a bar like this you
can see that there's still more strength
to this move right and that's you know
people always say cut your pro cut your
losses let your profits run they don't
really talk about that and when you're
using the order flow
and you know all of a sudden
hey there's more to this move
I don't have to
get out right now I could still ride it
a bit longer right and in this case
you're talking five six more points
now it comes up here again a new high
there was some selling that came in it
was at -39
and then flipped all the way up to 869
before closing at 7 20 okay still strong
right this Market is still strong
then it gets to this bar here right this
is your first sign of weakness
plus 461 Max Delta Min Delta was minus
88 and it closed at 422 or sorry just
22. so it went from plus 400 to just 22.
so it gave back a lot of that aggressive
buying I gave back almost all of it
right it was plus 461 on the max Delta
and the final Delta was just 22. so
that's a sign of the first you know
legitimate sign of some weakness coming
into the market then you just sort of go
sideways here you got these bars with
negative Delta
you know minus 9 minus 178 minus 218. so
you know there's selling is is kind of
building up in here right the aggressive
selling is getting a bit stronger does
pop up and make a new high here
okay
let's take a look at the Deltas
Max Delta was 203 okay fine we're making
new highs got positive Delta then the
sellers came in Min Delta minus 453 so
it went from plus 203 to minus
453. again a swing of about 650 it
closed at minus 369. so now you know
definitively sellers are in control
all right so what should you do should
be looking to take your profits finally
get out or potentially get short all
right next bar came in
negative Delta and you know it just sort
of went sideways to slightly lower after
that you know this is the candlesticks
and if you're looking at these
candlesticks you don't know that this
bar is strong
you don't know that this bar is strong
but that it's weakening in here I mean
people say well you got these doji
candle Etc yeah you know you just
grasping at straws you don't know the
strength of this bar here I mean people
say well it's you know it's a big green
big red candle yeah again you know you
could justify anything that you want but
if you have the data to back it up then
you know
you know yeah I can get short here and
take it you know if it's about seven
eight points right here
now this is a five minute Ultra Bond
chart but again yeah this is from
yesterday I just want to dig a little
bit deeper give you some more food for
thought on how you could use this in
your Trading
Okay so
Market sold off made this low rallied up
sold off again
okay and if you're watching what was
happening here this was interesting
because this Market is going down
and you're seeing the aggressive buying
coming in here right you see the buying
imbalances here 256 1100 big strong
positive Delta
okay even as this Market was going down
people say well how can this Market go
down you got the positive deltas
well look at this bar here
this red bar it had minus 353 Deltas was
quite strong negative Delta I mean
that's why you got the red bar but the
aggressive buyers were already stepping
in you're not seeing buying imbalances
yet I mean they haven't really popped to
this Market
but it went from -353 to just to plus
11. so basically back to even so the
aggressive buyers were showing up here
aggressive yeah you do have the positive
Delta of 167. then you get to this bar
here at the low the low of the day
very strong
aggressive point the Delta is 1200 63
1263 Max Delta is 1263.
okay
so
what's that telling you it's it's
closing on its Max Delta number and it's
telling you it's very strong
alrighty so you can see even though they
were selling in here you can already see
the signs that aggressive buying
appeared here all right you're still
seeing some aggressive buying in here
and obviously in this one right before
this Market pops up right you see the
aggressive buying is just so super
strong it closes on this Max Delta
number
even the Min Delta numbers are quite
small minus 39 minus 25.
all right so if you're seeing a bar like
this you know at your low your strongest
Max Delta in recent history it's closing
right on its Max Delta
we want to be long or short the trade is
to the upside and you can see it rallied
from you know basically 150 to 16 above
153 even
right that that's half a point move
in the
in the ultra ponds right it's a 500 move
in five minutes
and then as you see the aggressive
buying right don't just take it you know
sit on your laurels and say yeah I just
had a nice trade watch what's happening
right the aggressive buying 1263 954
195.
right you Unleashed All That aggressive
buying
but the market rallied yeah that's what
you expected but now you're seeing it
starting to weaken
1263 954 195 and then negative Delta up
at the swing High
minus 341 this move is over you're not
going to hold it anymore if anything
you're going to start thinking of
getting short
okay so that's how you could use like
Delta right it's Market generated
information
so pay attention to the volume of
trading activity if there's a sudden
increase or decrease in the number of
Trades being made right you can see that
through the Delta be an indication that
order flow is changing
so
let's get on to the meat and potatoes
all right using order flow to spot
opportunities in the market
s present opportunities every day it's
up to you to take advantage of them
But first you need to know how to spot
them or at least where they can occur
and where you take a trade opportunity
is just as important as spotting the
opportunity
so have you ask yourself have you ever
thought about Market structure people
seem you know traders that I know that
struggle
and you know I used to do private
coaching one-on-one for Traders and one
of the reasons why a lot of Traders
struggled is they don't think in terms
of Market structure
okay they just blindly oh there's a
signal I gotta take it I Gotta Buy or I
got to sell but you shouldn't do that
right you should ideally you know
understand the market structure because
there's areas where
you know you're going to want to be
buying and selling and there's areas
where even though you have a signal
you're not going to want to be buying or
selling you know areas inside the middle
of a range right inside of the middle of
a chop even though you get a signal
it's not going to be very effective
trade yeah sure you might you know the
trade might start in your favor go up a
couple ticks but then it's going to go
and stop you out you know you're going
to end up getting chopped up back and
forth
so what is trading around Market
structure well that means looking for
areas of Market generated support and
resistance you know areas where the
price is likely to pause or reverse
now these areas are generally
found around swing highs or swing lows
round numbers you know areas of volume
or other significant order flow activity
so what I'm going to talk about is
coupled today I'm going to talk about
stopping volume I'm going to talk about
a little bit something a little bit more
advanced is the value areas and now the
value areas I'm going to talk about are
in a bar
now
if you've ever looked at a chart and
wondered why did the market stop here
right I mean it sort of looked like it
stopped up here came off then it rallied
back up
made a new high right all these
Candlestick gurus oh you got a pin bar
here you gotta get short okay got Short
came right back up stop y'all I got
another one here oh you gotta get short
okay went back up stopped you out
right but if you understood order flow
when you see the market come back up in
here you know there's a nice reason for
getting short and
the volume that's being traded up in
here
is very bearish
but again you have to know what to look
for in the order flow and
one of the tools that we have in the
order flow Trader software that I
explained about earlier that I created
is a way to tell you when this volume
is bearish or when it's bullish and you
can see here
right it's colored red to tell you hey
this is bearish order flow
right because what's happening is the
market is going up this is the point of
control
it's what we call a Prominent Point of
control Prominent Point of controls you
have bearish ones you have bullish ones
bearish ones are going to be colored
sort of this magenta bullish ones will
be colored kind of a light blue cyan
color it's a very easy visual reference
because if you're looking at this oh you
know I've got a bearish order flow here
now I can start to analyze what's
happening you know
right now in the market to get short to
take advantage of it because if you're
looking at a bar chart
you know people you know they'll have
their swing low drawn in here oh you
know if we break here it's bearish well
where would you rather get short up in
here
or down here after you break this you
know the support area
well the better trade is to get short
from up here
you know 15 ticks higher 30 ticks higher
this is zero currency trading says in
half ticks is actually 30 ticks or yeah
36 higher because this is around the the
or sorry 80 area
this is around you know the 70 area so
it's 20 tick difference it's going to
give you a better opportunity to get
short because if you're getting short
down here you know where's your stop
well people say well it's here here you
know your stop would probably be more
realistically up here above this high so
imagine you're getting short one bar off
the high
then five bars off the high when the
Market's already dropped 20 ticks
but this is what we call a bearish
Prominent Point of control now every bar
has a point of control
point of control is the price level in
the bar with the most volume
but sometimes they're they're going to
give you signs of bearish activity and
bullish activity and that's why we have
the software to tell us when it's
bullish or when it's bearish
because again you can see here all these
bars just your normal point of control
they're nothing bullish or bearish about
them
but there's those instances where it is
very clear
based on the actual order flow that is
bearish
it's yesterday bonds right bonds Under
Pressure all day yesterday
Market popped up to here
sold off
simple stopping volume right you see
that point of control
highlighted for you easy to see that
it's
bearish right it's it's a red color
stopping volume what is stopping volume
well it's volume that
is there to defend
price levels
right you know Traders are stepping up
saying you know you're not on my watch
you're not getting through this price
level they're throwing everything in the
kitchen sink to stop the move the market
from continuing higher
Okay so yesterday in the e-minis right
that nice big monster rally okay now
people say well you know there's a pin
bar here of course you got to buy it
well you know I showed you a lot of pin
bars just now that failed right there's
a pin bar here that failed right it's a
pin bar here that failed
what made this one was this one so
special
the volume
all right this is the thing people will
say well there's price rejection here
the market went down and traded that
price and it rejected it well what's
your definition of price rejection
actually what you have here is
absorption right you got heavy volume
down in here and you can see it in the
point of control you see the point of
control is blue right it's the Prominent
Point of control it's a bullish one
and it's telling you heavy volume is
trading down here Traders are stepping
up
to absorb whatever selling is happening
in that market and if you knew
that there was absorption down here
as opposed to oh I just got a pin bar I
got to buy it blindly
you're gonna have more confidence in
your Trading
right and this was a monster move 39 30
all the way up into the 70s
almost a 50-point move there
and that was really the
the icing the cherry on top right is
that volume right that point of control
there telling you that
you know there's absorption going on
there's price defense people are saying
not on my watch
now when you think of price rejection
price rejection would be the opposite
it'd be very thin volume
but this is heavy volume
Okay and like I said you know people
will say well you know there's a pin bar
here right that's what caused this
Market to go up well fine here's a
couple other pin bars here run here one
here but there's no stopping volume
involved here just your normal point of
controls
but these ones yeah I mean technically
the market went up a couple of points
but
it's not the
70 point move right here
I'll show you 50 point move
so that's the difference that order flow
is going to help you
see in the market right it's going to
see where there's stopping volume in the
market because when they're stopping
volume when there's price defense you
know that's basically a Line in the Sand
you know Traders are saying you know not
on my watch you want me on that wall you
need me on that wall
right they're stepping up to the plate
to stop any movements from going down
so by trading around Market generated
levels and you know Market generated
information levels you could better
understand
where the market is likely to go next
and make more informed trading decisions
of course the market structure can and
will change over time so it's important
to stay aware of the latest developments
and again just to reiterate what is
market generated information it's data
that's created as a result of actual
trading activity in the market not
orders going in and out of the order
book right not orders that are sitting
in the market that you know may have
trade towards may not trade towards
it's actual traded volume
so Market generated information or
include things like price changes
trading volume and Order imbalances
now this next concept that I'll talk
about is the importance of value areas
and it's it's a more advanced concept
for Traders to understand now if you're
familiar with volume profile Market
profile
um
you you're familiar with the term of a
value area right it's the area
on where majority usually 70 of the
volume occurs right of the trading day
because volume profile Market profile
tend to look at trading days
but with order flow you can actually
take it on a more micro level on a bar
by bar basis now a lot of times you see
charts
Market pulls back to a certain level
stops and then continues on it's in its
direction
okay if you know you sort of draw
retracements here you know it's not
really a 50 retracement it's not a 38
you know people say well maybe it's
still 61 from this level you know
there's always
trying to redraw their retracement
levels to sort of fit their narrative
right I mean it might be a 38
retracement from this level here to here
you know 61 from here to here
you know 23 for me oh yeah you know see
it's converting yeah come on man that
you're really just pulling at straws
there's got to be an easier way
now
at that dip area here yeah we have a
bullish Prominent Point of control
that's that's formed
now the thing is
bullish Prime opponent controls
you don't really know about them until
they form right
what if you had a way to see a level
where the market might pull back
before it actually pulls back here right
it's nice to get that Prominent Point of
control in this bar
but if you know that there's a level
coming out from right in here
yeah
that's gold basically
and by using the value areas you can see
those areas
where there was support based off of
previous Market activity
right right here right this is that
little place it pulled back to but in
here this is the value area in a bar
right and you can see it being drawn out
here what we call an abandoned value
area where the next bar doesn't trade
into it now you have another one up here
okay and the markets did pull back here
and just you went one two three four
bars in into it this one
held better than this one but you know
that when the market is trading up in
here
it's got potential to come back to o5
it's got the potential to come back to
O2
so imagine you're throwing a bid at o5
okay got stopped out throwing a bid at
O2 you're filled right and then the
market went from O2
right in here all the way up to 12.
so what is happening is the market is
referencing a value area from earlier
this is the value area from earlier that
it's referencing
now again software
that's the beauty of software is it can
draw out these areas that are left
abandoned like this like this one here
this one here
so value areas that are abandoned
meaning the next bar did not retrace
back into it often act as magnets now
there's different ways to trade these
abandoned value areas number one is
for the market to repair them what that
means is for the market to come back to
that level okay the other thing is to go
with it right after the next bar
abandons that value area you know that
volume is transitioning higher right and
very early in this training I said when
markets you know when volume is
transition is you know when
volume is picking up that's when you the
markets tends to move right and more
importantly when Market when volume is
picking up in a Direction
that you know that the market is
probably going to continue in that
direction so for example right go with
the abandoned value so abandon value
here abandoned value here abandoned
value here
you don't know of course until the next
bar closes that didn't retrace back in
but if you went with it here you got a
little move here pulls back it's holding
and more abandoned value
again you just go with it
right so it's a great go with trade here
right abandoned value then it takes off
right here's your value area that's
abandoned because most of the time it's
going to overlap
or it's going to trade back into it
again
now
hang on a second I'm gonna drink some
water
now the key is
you know you understand that has value
is transitioning one way or the other
then
you know that buyer's perception of the
market has changed because they're more
willing to pay higher prices
because they've already accepting that
value is moving higher
now there's going to be times where it
just goes sideways like this right it
came off it's kind of holding here
holding here so we're going sideways and
comes back in and it failed okay I mean
it's not the
end all be all that you know you got
abandoned value area it's gonna forever
hold
like here it came off it's holding it
comes back up into it just kisses the
edges what you see a lot of times where
it just sort of comes back in kisses the
edge
and then makes its move
now
when you start looking at longer term
charts this is a five minute chart you
know most of the charts I showed you
earlier were just simple one minute
charts you know whether you could use it
on tick based charts you could use it on
Range based charts
um I don't think you can't use it on
wrinkle charts
but when you start going out into a
little bit longer time frame five
minutes
it really becomes a bit in my opinion A
Bit Stronger right here's a nice one
right abandoned value area nice move
down 103 down to you know 102.75 or even
here is 102.80 where you had a support
line from earlier right you see how this
Market came down to this area
and then it's kind of holding it's kind
of going sideways right actually so over
the next
25 30 minutes it was just going sideways
in that area this was your support area
so if you're short from up here
and you start coming into this level and
it's going sideways you know that okay
yeah I could take profits already
15 minute chart
okay same thing right MGI support level
Market generated information
Market went up nice move up
all right even here is another support
level Market came off you gotta
resistance area up in here this red area
this red area this red area well look
what happens
Market went up started coming off it
came down to the support area all right
then you got resistance here it came
right into the resistance
all right now you got a new resistance
level here Market sells off word is it
coming to it comes right to the support
area
I mean it doesn't get any in my opinion
any any simpler than that this is Apple
stock
okay I had to scrunch it up I mean I'm
not concerned with what the
footprint volume numbers are in this
case
um but I scrunched it up to show you
right Market rallied right you got your
abandoned value areas here
one two Market rallies but where does it
stop it stops right up at this area
where you had your previous abandoned
value area
all right so if you're along from here
you understand why it stops here right
that's that's really the whole key in
trading is understanding why markets
move and more importantly why markets
stop why did it stop here it's coming
down it's testing the support area right
here
okay Apple again
all right this is a go with trade right
just came back here just kissing the top
and then it went for it right then it
made its run
so Apple again right
abandoned value area up here Market sold
off where'd it sell off to
the area where you had the market
generated support right here the
previous value then the market rallied
from this area to where here where you
had your resistance level
I mean you know it's I I wish I could
say every single chart is going to be as
beautiful as this it's not so there's
times where it just sort of it can blow
through it but if you know where these
areas are beforehand
right it's going to help you manage your
trade a lot better in my opinion
you know so hopefully you can start to
see you know the benefits of using
order flow right because you know at the
end of the day that's what you want to
do right you want to use order flow to
to help your Trading
so over the last 45 minutes actually
it's more like last hour I've covered a
lot of ground right you've learned the
basics of order flow trading and you've
hopefully seen how it can help you make
better trading decisions
you've also learned about some of the
key tools and resources that are
available to order flow Traders so
hopefully you'll agree that it's been
time well spent right I've certainly
think so I like to think you know that
you've Come Away Learning something but
again in just a short amount of time
you've learned a lot about a complex
topic right order flow is not as it's
not basic right it's not a simple thing
you do need to wrap your head around
some key issues
so I can't cover everything
in a quick training session like this I
mean I wish I could but there's just so
much more to learn about order flow
Trading
but I hope that now you have a good
understanding of water flow basics
but if you're interested in learning
more
I have a very special offer for you it's
the order flows Trader 5.0
now you've seen some of the tools like
the value areas the imbalances
the multiple imbalances things like that
and really what it is think of it like
this right have you ever wished you get
inside the minds of professional Traders
and see what they're thinking with the
order flow Trader version 5.0 I'm on the
fifth version of the software since we
released it in 20
15.
you can do that right this is software
that takes my knowledge to trading order
flow and puts it into a program so you
can see what institutional Traders are
doing in the market so with this
valuable information at your fingertips
you're going to be able to make smarter
more profitable trading decisions now
I do realize right many Traders think
that having the right software is all
they need to be to be successful in
trading
however this could not be further from
the truth if you don't know how to use
the software it won't do you any good
that's why I focus on providing
education on how to trade with order
flow I want my students to be successful
and I know that starts with giving them
tools they need to understand the
markets
once you have a solid foundation you can
begin to place trades with confidence
and that's when the real success starts
to happen
so not only do you get the software but
you get
educational courses right you're going
to get my order flow trading course
which normally sells for 297 you're
gonna get it for free there's 20 lessons
in there it's the first course on
trading order flow that was on the
market I mean a lot of people have
actually taken my courses and
copied them Rewritten them and try to
pawn them off at their own but this is
you know this is I'm the source for a
lot of this information that's out there
nowadays
you're gonna get it for free right the
order flow trading course but more
importantly you're going to get the
order flow Inner Circle video series
which you honestly you can't buy anymore
I don't sell it I'd only make it
available with the software and when I
did sell it it was close to 500 but
there's 56 videos on Advanced order flow
tricks tips and Analysis
so you start adding it together
all right it's starting to add up right
it's almost you know 8.99 for the
software 297 for the the order flow
trading course 497 for the Inner Circle
video series
yeah that's almost Seventeen hundred
dollars but again you're not gonna pay
that today now
I realize it's one thing to learn from
videos and books you know the training
courses Etc but it takes discipline and
it takes commitments
and what I've found very helpful to
Traders is live training where you can
ask me questions
and so for the last three years I've
been hosting live user sessions for all
users to join where I drive home what I
saw in the order flow the past week and
you could ask questions about you know
areas where you may be struggling with
your analysis you know my thoughts on
markets my thoughts on parts of order
flow Etc it's up to you it's a free
um Forum in the sense that
you can ask whatever you want and
you know the other day today's Thursday
I just had it on Tuesday I spent maybe
the first half talking about you know
some interesting things I saw in the
order flow in the second half answering
you know questions ranging from
um you know hey I look at this Market
what do you think is useful to trading
Ultra bonds right or
um what's a good way to use imbalances
there's so many different ways now the
archives if you can't attend the live
it's recorded so you could watch the
replay the archives have actually it
says 157 here but it's much more than
that's over 170 already
and there are people out there that sell
you software and then expect you to pay
extra to learn how to use it what you
know you're making an investment to
learn how to trade
you don't want to keep paying bits and
pieces you know the nickel and Diamond
needed to death
right but what I discussed today is just
a small sample of the kinds of analysis
I talk about on a weekly basis in the
live Group Training and what could be
found in my inner circle video series I
go into much more detail though about
aspects of trading from technical
analysis to fundamental analysis I also
talk about the different trading
strategies I use and how to adapt them
to changing market conditions and much
more so if you're serious about trading
then I highly recommend you get started
now
so to get started now you go to
orderflows.com oft5
now in these weekly sessions you're
probably going to learn more than you
ever thought possible
I put the link in the chat it's this
link down here orderflows.com
off5.html and when you type that into
your browser it takes you to this page
okay and you're gonna have to scroll
down
I mean there's some videos you could
watch there some examples of you know
how you could use the software
and you just click this button here to
get started click here to buy now you're
going to get lifetime access to the
order flows Trader 5.0 any upgrades are
free we do have an upgrade coming out
later this year
and you know I've got people have been
using this since we first launched it in
in 2015 they're still using it seven
years later they've gone through all the
upgrades
and you know
they're just
happy to be better Traders so you get
access to the order flow trading course
the Inner Circle video series
weekly live group trainings and I've
even got a special bonus which I'll talk
about in a minute the order flows
Playbook
now when you click on this button it
takes you to PayPal PayPal processes
your payments now all the download
information license tokens course logins
Etc is sent to your PayPal registered
email address whatever email you use to
log in here
this is the email it will go to
so check that in again if it doesn't hit
your inbox check your spam folder now it
does since I do create you know all
these course logins right because we do
have a lot of bonuses it does take time
so you know give it you know we're
usually pretty quick to turn around is
usually within you know an hour but you
know for whatever reason sometimes takes
a little bit longer to get the email
from PayPal that you purchased you know
it could take a couple hours
but just bear that in mind I mean some
people you don't get it till the next
day now
all you got to do it's just a one-time
payment of 7.49 there's no recurring
monthly payment you know there's no I
don't hit you up you know a year later
with another payment for 7.49 or charge
you 29 a month forever that you gotta
cancel your credit card and then still
get in charge somehow to your bank
account you got to close that bank
account to cancel no none of that
nonsense it's just a one-time payment
now
you will obviously have to pay data fees
ninjatrader fees my software runs on
ninjatrader 8.
again it's just a one-time payment 749
very affordable
now as a special bonus
for investors Expo people you get the
orderful Playbook normally it's 297 you
can get it for free it's a short course
on order flows a little bit Advanced
topics and also in there there's about I
think it's 10 or 11 additional trade
setups that you can learn about and look
for in the markets
so to get started go to orderflows.com
opt5 again the link is in the chat what
you're going to get is the order flows
Trader 5.0
overflow trading course
if you value that 297 order flow Inner
Circle value to 497.
or a full live weekly Group Training you
know what's that value that's like
minimum 200 a month I've seen people
they have these quote trading groups
and they charge you know 197 a month for
what you know just spend all this money
on your software you should make it for
free the order flows Playbook value is
is 297 plus the software or illustrator
5.0 will win free upgrades when they
happen
you know it's 8.99 but you're not going
to do that right is this going to be 749
now I did write a book on trading order
flow okay it's called
appropriately trading order flow and you
know that was
when I sat down to write it
um you know I thought this is going to
be my my contribution to the market
trading world
and you know it's about 150 pages
but I'll show you how to get it for free
just go to this page
orderflows.com slash book.html enter
your name and email address and click
submit it will take you to a page where
you can download it you're not going to
get the actual hardcovering book you can
get a downloadable PDF so that you can
you know download it to your phone to
your computer print it up do whatever
you want with it make your notes
so just go to orderflows.com book.html
to get started with the book and to get
started with the software go to
orderflows.com
5.html
so just remember right in the end we
only get the chances we didn't take you
know
when a couple years ago when covet hit
you know I know a lot of people said
yeah you know what I'm going to do this
I'm going to do that and they never took
action they never did anything
right then a year later two years later
they're right back where they started
from and the same thing is with trading
right you want to become a better Trader
you got to take that first step you
gotta
you got to take action right and I try
to make it as easy as possible for you
to succeed with trading specifically
with trading order flow not just by
having in my opinion the best software
out there but also by having the best
education out there
right so again you know get started just
go to opt5
overflows.com oft5.html
so just a quick question here um
I don't know who this is uh just says
asking this member I'm a customer of
order flow software 3.0 can I upgrade
yeah you should have already you know
I've sent you links
check your spam folder right because
whenever we do an upgrade I usually send
about 10 emails like an email a day for
the first week
um you know about the upgrade so
sometimes people it goes to your spam
folder but just send me an email right
if for some reason you aren't getting my
emails because you know sometimes
you know especially if you've got like a
Yahoo email it does uh send a lot of
emails to the spam folder Gmail is much
better is there a trial version Sammy
Simmy asks sorry
um no there's no not a trial version
anymore
um yeah we used to have it but then it
was just getting abused by people so I
mean honestly our prices are pretty
reasonable that
if you don't you know it's not
overwhelming yeah unfortunately it only
works with ninjatrader
um you know that was the software that
years ago I mean you know again going
back into 2013
2014 2015
um as far in terms of you know as a
retail Trader there wasn't as many
platforms as you have out there now and
you know the programmer I love my
programmers is the greatest one out
there in my opinion especially now I
could just go to him you know sort of
sketch out ideas and say hey this is
what I'm looking for
um and and you know a couple days later
he's got the solution for me you know in
terms of
um you know programming the stuff you
know you know there are knocks against
an intertrader but honestly it's just a
stable platform as long as you're not
overloading your system
and what type of data feeds
Okay so
if you
are going the ninjatrader
route you know if you're getting my
software you're going to go through
ninjatrader of course but
you just need level one data you don't
need level two data so
what I would suggest is especially you
know if you're not actively trading
right now
um or maybe you're trading on a
different front-end system with a
different broker
the way to get the um you can get data
for a very inexpensive fee you know
sixty dollars a month more or less I'm
paying for and I've got CME cbot
nymex and eurx I've actually got level
two data for all but if you're just
going to level one data because I pay
like 60 a month sixty five dollars a
month for real-time data that's coming
through ninjatrader brokerage now what
some people do I know that trade through
you know a different front-end system
with the different Brokers they just
open up a simple account at ninjatrader
brokerage you know throw a couple
hundred dollars in there because if you
were to pay for data separately
you know one exchange CMEs it's like
over a hundred dollars real-time
Exchange
um but again you know
best case scenario you'd trade through a
ninja Trader broker so I'm not trying to
pimp them out saying they're they're the
greatest brokerage ever I don't get any
feed I don't get anything back from them
for it but um you know for me they've
been fine right I've never had any
issues with them
so
that uh should answer your question so
again you know if you just had simple
level one data for CME
cblt call Max and IMAX
you know you're going to talk around 50
a month for those three exchanges
real-time data feed
so again everybody
um to get started just go to
orderflows.com off5 the link is in the
chat
so hopefully um again you'll learn
something to get my book go to
orderflows.com book.html
and I hope to see you guys on the inside
so I'll just leave it there thanks again
uh Anna for having me and it's always a
pleasure
to talk to your crowd so bye bye
everybody have a great rest of your week